YouTube, listen up,
YouTube: What do you want PooPooPie?
PewDiePie: You know goddamn well what I want. I thought we had a deal...
YouTube: We made good on the deal PooPooPies, why do you call us again?
PoopyDie: Okay, I'm calling you because I need more views
YouTube: But you can't have anymore views;
you've exhausted the likes, the dislikes, and the comments...
PoopyPants: There's always a way to milk it
YouTube: You have made over ten thousand of these videos now, you can't possibly make another one
PeePie: I'll find a way, you son of a bitch. I'll find a way!
Youtube: You'll never do it PooPooPie... Your SOUL is- *Felix ends the call*
CAN WE GET THE SAME AMOUNT OF LIKES AS DISLIKES
ON THIS VIDEO?!?!?!?!?!?!
Camera Man: Oh Jesus...
Camera Man: ohh, that actually got me in the dick
AHHH
AHHHHHHHH
CAN WE GET THE SAME AMOUNT OF LIKES AS DISLIKES!?
SAME AMOUNT OF LIKES AS DISLIKES!
SAME AMOUNT OF LIKES AS DIS- *laughs*
SAME AMOUNT OF LIKES AS DISLIKES!!!
Do people even know what this video is about?
Do people understand the same amount of likes?
Same amount... you get the same amount of likes as dislikes
So like, 500 likes and 500 dislikes, can we get that on the video? How do we get them to understand that?
*Screeching on bullhorn*  SAME AMOUNT OF LIKES AS DISLIKES
Can we do it?
OHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!
Camera Man: There's a fuckin' woman...
*laughs*
*sirens*
*more sirens*
*still sirens*
*WEE OO WEE OO WEE OO*
[I've run out of things to say about sirens but they're still here]
*turns siren off*
Camera Man: Shut the fuck up!
*BEEP*
Can we get the same amount of likes as dislikes, boy?!
*distant beeping*
*beeping grows louder*
*beeping stops*
*beeping returns*
SAME AMOUNT OF LIKES AS DISLIKES!!!
*beeping continues, growing softer*
*intense music*
SAME AMOUNT OF LIKES AS DISLIKES
SAME AMOUNT OF LIKES AS DISLIKES... CAN WE DO IT?
Same amount of likes as dislikes?  *Repeats "Same amount of likes as dislikes please?" estoy como dance por favor
Same amount of likes as dislikes... Can we smash it?
*Honks*
Same amount of likes as dislikes...?
*Beeps and Honks*
Can we get same amount of likes as dislikes?
Same amount of likes... as dislikes...
*Sad Music Plays*
Same amount of likes...
Same amount...
SAME AMOUNT OF LIKES...
SAME! *murmurs* Same amount of likes...
*Sad Music*
Camera Man: What are you gonna do next time?
Camera Man: Huh, there is no way you can do another one of these...
PewDiePie: I'LL THINK OF SOMETHING
Camera Man: There is no way you can make more of these
PewDiePie: I'LL THINK OF SOMETHING, GOD DAMMIT!!!!!  AHHHH!!!